-Now, John, I'm sure
you get asked this a lot,
but can you give us any spoilers
from "The Rise of Skywalker"?
-I'm in enough trouble so, no,
I'm going to keep my mouth shut.
-Fair enough.
Fair enough.
Maybe we could at least give
some spoilers of things
that definitely won't be
in "The Rise of Skywalker."
-I can do that.
-All right. It's time for
"Things You Won't Hear
in 'Star Wars.'"
♪♪
♪ Things you won't hear
in "Star Wars" ♪
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-You won't hear Darth Vader say,
"Luke, I'm your daddy."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You won't hear
Obi-Wan Kenobi say,
"Dang it, I forgot to wear
Spanx under my robe today.
Hashtag Jedi fail!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Robot wails ]
-You won't hear Yoda say,
"Just saw Dobby from
'Harry Potter' on Tinder. Mmm!
Did I?
Right swipe, I will."
[ Robot beeps ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You won't hear Finn say,
"The only reason I switched
sides was because
I saw the 'Can you hear me now?'
guy switch
from Verizon to Sprint, so --"
[ Blip ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You won't hear
Luke Skywalker say,
"I have nipples, Greg.
Can you milk me?"
[ Laughter and cheering ]
[ Robot wails ]
[ Applause ]
-You won't hear C3PO say,
"Okay, boomer."
[ Laughter ]
[ Robot beeps ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You won't hear
Supreme Leader Snoke say,
"I just took a DNA test.
Turns out I'm 100% that Sith."
[ Laughter ]
[ Robot noises ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You won't hear Boba Fett say,
"I like hunting
for the Millennium Falcon,
but I love hunting for
Black Friday deals at Kohl's."
[ Laughter ]
[ Robot noises ]
[ Applause ]
-You won't hear Rey say,
"BB-8, you still need to --"
Ven-- wait. That's some
American stuff. Venmo?
[ Laughter ]
Wait, let me take it again.
-Yeah.
-You won't hear Rey say,
"BB-8, you still need to
Venmo me for our Uber.
Your round, bitch."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Robot beeps ]
-And finally, you won't hear
Kylo Ren say,
"You think Baby Yoda is cute?
Well, check out Hot Yoda."
[ Robot wails ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I can't wait to not hear
all those things
in "Star Wars:
The Rise of Skywalker."
[ Cheers and applause ]
My thanks to John Boyega!
[ Cheering ]
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with more of "The Tonight Show,"
everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪